now this brings us to the remains found
this afternoon at colville bay at lake
mead madison kimbrough spoke with two
women who made that startling discovery
she joins us live in the newsroom with
more on what we know so far madison lake
mead is a normal hangout for these
locals of henderson sisters lindsay and
lynette melvin were paddle boarding this
afternoon when they made the call into
park rangers
it looked like a rock from afar but
upon further inspection it looked
clearly like bone and then we kind of
started to move the sand around the
skull just to kind of get an idea of
what it actually was a day at the lake
turns into a startling find as more
human remains were found in the sand at
lake mead this time at caulville bay
where lindsey melvin was paddle boarding
with her sister lynette saturday
afternoon at first i thought it was a
big horn sheep and we kind of started
digging around a little bit as we
discovered the jaw we realized it was
human remains and that's when we
contacted park rangers to come and
investigate for the longest time i was
in disbelief like i did not think that
we actually just came upon human remains
lindsay who's an rn says she's used to
seeing things like this but for it not
to be in the typical hospital setting is
unnerving it's definitely surreal
but
i think there's a larger part of me that
is kind of happy that this person was
found because i'm sure that they do have
family that wants to know what happened
to them and with the water levels
continuing to drop in lake mead the
likelihood of more bodies surfacing is
probable as metro police have already
received numerous tips since the first
discovery on may first
and the clark county coroner's office is
working to identify the remains
discovered today sources tell the 8 news
now i-team there are no signs of foul
play and at this point metro police are
not involved in the investigation live
in the newsroom madison kimbrough live
local now